Isis is over that's some news I guess
that it was pretty quick wasn't it
maddis general mattis told us back in
April that Trump had given him a mandate
to annihilate Isis and now guess what
Isis is annihilated Iraq president Prime
Minister rather hadir al Abadi and
Iranian president Hassan rouhani
announced victory today for those with
short memories Isis developed in 2013
during the Barack Obama administration
in the power vacuum created by Barack
Obama's very stupid decision to pull
American forces out of Iraq but in
fairness to Barack Obama how could he
have known how could Obama have known
that pulling troops out of Iraq would
lead to the rise of an even more
dangerous threat than we were already
fighting our nation deserves a serious
debate about Iraq because the outcome of
this conflict will have enormous
consequences for our country failure in
Iraq would allow terrorists to operate
from a safe haven with access to the
world's third-largest oil reserves very
Iraq would increase the probability that
at some later date American troops would
have to return to Iraq to confront an
enemy more dangerous and more entrenched
failure Iraq was centered on this
unmistakable signal to America's enemies
that our country can be bullied into
retreat America's involvement in Iraq
does not have to end this way what a
dummy huh what it I can't believe anyone
ever believed that guy you know that guy
that just perfectly predicted every
single thing that would happen after he
left office yeah you know that guy even
predicting what his opponent Barack
Obama what his political opponent Barack
Obama would end up doing and all of the
terrible things that followed from that
what did we get just a few years later
let's take a look this is James Wright
folding an American citizen of your
country as a government you have been at
the forefront of the aggression towards
Islamic state you have plotted against
us and gone far out of your way to find
our faith that was jihad John and we
tolerated him beheading a lot of
Americans Americans james foley steven
sotloff peter kassig among many others
were gruesomely beheaded by
on Brock Obama's watch though the most
chilling actually may have been Isis's
simultaneous beheading of 21 Coptic
Christians who were crying at their
belief in yeshua on a beach in tripoli
while barack obama was apologizing for
the crusades or whatever other nonsense
he was doing an office Isis also shot up
a Tunisian tourist resort killing 38
Europeans he bomb rather Isis bombed
Turkey and killed 33 crashed a Russian
airplane killing 224 bombs Turkey again
they kept bombing Turkey the bombed
Beirut attacked Paris killing 130
civilians bombed Istanbul Brussels
killing 32 nice killing 86 attacked
Kabul killing 80 Berlin killing 12 st.
Petersburg killing 15 Manchester killing
22 and many many other attacks after all
with all that weight of evidence how
would Barack Obama describe the group
[Music]
enemies his choice of war is getting a
lot of attention in an interview with
The New Yorker magazine it compares
groups linked to al-qaeda to an amateur
basketball team quote the analogy we use
around here sometimes and I think is
accurate is if a JV team meaning junior
varsity team puts on Lakers uniforms
that doesn't make them Kobe Bryant end
quote
doesn't make him Kobe Bryant they're
just the JV team isn't that what Barack
Obama did this from the beginning of his
campaign onward he was operating under
the belief that if he would say things
that would make them true he clearly
suffered from some version of narcissism
and very frequently he would just say
things that obviously didn't comport
with reality but nevertheless he said a
lie often enough told will become a
truth what exactly did he mean by the JV
team we think we have an idea but he
goes on and explains it in another
interview what I do insist on is is that
we maintain proper perspective
and that we do not provide a victory to
these terrorist networks by over
inflating their importance and
suggesting in some fashion that they are
an existential threat to the United
States or the world order yeah you know
they're not what how would they be an
existential threat they're the JV team
they're not wreaking havoc all over the
entire globe and destroying a region
destroying two nations in a region and
challenging American credibility there
the existential threat is crucial here
because we're talking about an ideology
that has been encroaching and fighting
the West for fourteen hundred years
we're talking about political Islamism
and Barack Obama for whatever reason
refused to see that as an existential
threat to the West he he also famously
made fun of Mitt Romney for saying that
Russia was the greatest geopolitical
threat probably because Barack Obama
thinks the greatest threats are from
within or something he couldn't seem to
identify an actual geopolitical threat
to the United States now because he
didn't consider them an existential
threat he didn't pursue them here's
Barack Obama explaining that strategy
says that what you have on the ground
now is not going to be enough every
couple of months you're going to be
faced with the same choice back down or
double down I think what is true is that
this has always been a multi-year
project unbelievable mealy-mouthed this
is what happens by the way when I'm late
writing a piece or writing up a show or
god-king Jeremy boring or ben shapiro
they come to me they say where's the
peace I say look look look this has
always been a multi-year project look
this has always been we just need
strategic patience we just need to lead
from behind but clearly he had no
interest in fighting Isis whatsoever we
don't know we know that he wanted to be
a domestic policy president we also know
that he failed at every level when it
came to foreign policy